for years fans have been enjoying Pawn
Stars the reality show about the
Harrison family and their famed gold and
silver pawn shop in Las Vegas but this
isn't even the family's first taste of
TV stardom as they were previously
featured on both Comedy Central and PBS
and before that the cast members each
had long and interesting lives and
careers outside of television surprised
here's a look at the Pawn Stars before
all the fame the old man Richard
Benjamin Harrison better known as the
old man was born on March 4th 1941 in
Danville Virginia to what his son Rick
described in his 2011 memoir licensed
upon as dirt poor white trash left to
survive on their wits he helped the
family make ends meet by driving a
school bus at the age of 14 which had to
be pretty surreal for the other kids on
the bus
in 1960 Richards life changed
drastically just before his marriage to
a girl named Joanne Roux who he met at a
barn dance
Richard was arrested for stealing a car
instead of serving jail time he chose to
join the Navy he served for 20 years
eventually moving the family to the
naval hub of San Diego where he and his
wife took up real estate but when the
housing market collapsed in the early
80s he decided to switch careers moving
his family to Las Vegas to focus on
buying and selling gold and the rest as
they say is history Rick Harrison the
charismatic face of Pawn Stars Rick
Harrison's early life was a struggle
diagnosed with epilepsy at age 8
Rick was confined to his bed for
treatment and found his escape in
reading and eventually in drugs which
began with a joint in the fourth grade
by the time the family moved to Las
Vegas Rick had become a slick wheeler
dealer selling fake Gucci bags to pay
the bills he quit that gig to help the
old man open a pawn shop but there was
one problem local laws banned pawn shops
inside the city limits until the city's
population hit a quarter of a million
people that delayed the dream but it
didn't end it and in 1988 the Gold &
Silver Pawn Shop opened its doors with
an initial investment of just ten
thousand dollars big Hoss warned Rick on
April 27th 1983 when Rick was just 18
Cory's childhood took place almost
entirely inside the Gold & Silver Pawn
Shop he started working at the shop at
the age of nine eventually turning that
entry-level position at the store
polishing jewelry into a managerial
position with a 5% cut and the promise
of taking over the family business once
Rick and the old man retire in 2011 the
big Hoss got a lot smaller shedding
close to 200 pounds thanks to a gastric
lap band surgery and dietary changes
designed to help stave off the
possibility of diabetes
good job big Hoss Chumlee the goofy
honorary member of the family who always
seems a step away from getting fired
Austin Chumlee Russell was born on
September 8 1982 his nickname of Chumlee
came from the cartoon Tennessee tuxedo
Chumlee being The Walrus sidekick of the
titular penguin Lee now Chumlee would
you please toss up the sports section
I'll bring it myself
a childhood friend of Cory's Chumlee
joined the staff the
and silver when he was 21 and has been a
constant presence at the shop ever since
including at the Harrisons Christmas
dinner the Harrisons loved to make light
of their friend and his semi frequent
lapses in judgment they just make Cuban
cigars in America chum is probably one
the dumbest thing sheriff said despite
that or perhaps because of it he's
widely considered the most popular
member of the group with the shops own
profile page claiming grills get nervous
around him like perhaps one direction of
the Biebs has just walked into the room
take that with a grain of salt of course
but there's no denying that chump is an
aid to the Harrisons especially with his
knowledge of games pinball machines and
sneakers my god that man loves his
sneakers so this is a lot of my
collection but it's not really it this
isn't everything thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this other cool stuff we know you love
to
[Music]